[Music]
- I'll do not there is no try
sighs messagenet look at me
that's me by my size do you for my Ally
is the force and the powerful it is
bleats it makes it grow its energy
surrounds us and binds us luminous
beings are we not this crude matter you
must feel the force around you you
betrayed you me every way hey everybody
its Charlie this is gonna be my new
Mandalorian baby yoda video we're
getting close to the finale so there's a
couple of big plot lines they have to
wrap up and he's already demonstrated
some crazy force abilities so we'll
break it all down be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos if you're brand
new to my channel I'll be doing videos
for the Mandalorian they're already
shooting season two right now so I will
talk about what's going on with season
two when we get closer to the finale
obviously careful for spoilers if you
have not seen episode 6 yet but at the
very end of episode 6 you see baby Yoda
getting ready to use the force to stop
zero the droid when he's getting ready
to shoot him but before he can the
Mandalorian shoots him from behind in a
big twist through the chest before he
can see the Mandalorian behind the Droid
though baby Yoda curiously looks at his
hand in wonders if he really just did
that the Droid collapses to the ground
revealing the Mandalorian in his line of
sight and then he understands what
happened so everybody was wondering what
was going to happen had the Mandalorian
not shown up would he have been able to
actually stop him from shooting him with
a blaster and the thing is just based on
the scenes we've already seen and what
they've implied he's totally strong
enough to have saved himself in that
situation he's clever enough to hide
from him like I made a bunch of jokes
about him teleporting during my episode
6 video but the truth is that he's just
way quicker on his feet than he looks
because he's so small and because he has
those tiny little claws on his fingers
it makes it way easier for him to climb
things sometimes you forget because you
don't see Yoda hold his hands up that
much during the trilogy but if you look
at Yoda's hand he's got some pretty
serious claw
there even without using the force baby
Yoda could probably cost someone's eyes
out if he got close enough based on what
we've seen him do so far though there's
only a couple of force abilities I think
that would be useful to the kid in this
situation so when he focuses attention
like this baby Yoda is powerful enough
to one deflect the blaster shot at very
close range
remember back in Episode four with the
sniper that almost got him I don't think
he would have been able to stop that
shot because he wasn't focusing he
wasn't paying attention to it into he's
not strong enough to sense it coming
from that far away and even though he's
innately very powerful in the force he's
not strong enough to slow time around
him or move quickly enough he talked
about Jedi being able to slow their
body's functions down a little bit but
the most powerful force users both Jedi
and Sith can't slow the relative flow of
time around their bodies so for the most
part we know that baby Yoda's powers are
limited to line-of-sight he's a very
smart baby but he's still an infant so
he has to be able to see the thing that
he's using the force on based on what
we've seen we also know that he can
force push the droid back so that his
shot would miss if he can lift the mud
horn then he can push something smaller
like the droid back in a simple force
push is one of the most basic Jedi
skills he could also use the Force to
throw something at the Droid or the gun
causing him to misfire and then maybe if
he were really close like this he could
also jam the trigger but that's a bit of
a stretch because he'd had to understand
how the gun works
and even though baby Yoda is very
intuitive in his environment around him
and he can sense what the Mandalorian is
feeling or the people around him are
feeling I don't think that he
understands how the gun works but those
are about all the low-level abilities
that baby Oda could probably use in that
situation only the most powerful Jedi or
Sith masters have been able to absorb or
redirect energy without a lightsaber so
Yoda versus Count Dooku is a good
example of that I've become more
powerful than any Jedi
[Music]
because of his training Count Dooku has
learned to use force lightning so he
uses that against Master Yoda in the
most basic ability of a Jedi in this
situation would be to deflect the energy
so that it just goes off and hits
something else but if your Master Yoda
one of the most powerful Jedi in the
galaxy at this time next to say someone
like the Emperor or Anakin Skywalker you
can actually absorb that energy and use
it to recharge yourself because it takes
a lot of energy to use the Force so
there's a biological limit to what Jedi
can do eventually you just get too tired
even if you're a super powerful Jedi
Master like Yoda there are a couple ways
to replenish that energy you can pass
out like baby Yoda for a couple days and
just sleep it off that's the simple way
if you're a Sith you can use life tap
and just steal life force from another
living being recharging yourself or like
Yoda here you can absorb raw energy but
that's like a god tier Jedi ability
which is why you never see anyone else
doing it in the movies given the force
powers baby Yoda has already shown that
he's capable of there's still a couple
of low level abilities and simple tricks
that will probably see him do before the
end of the series some of that stuff
they'll probably save for season -
they're not gonna blow their wad
completely in the season finale this
year but one of the biggest and most
simple ones like I just said or force
pushes levitating people not just
animals like levitating stormtroopers so
it's implied that there's a hornet's
nest of Imperial remnants that are after
the Mandalorian and baby Yoda eventually
they're gonna have to reckon with that
sometime in the finale there's also the
idea of him using the Force to throw
things around like the shiny little ball
gear that he's so fascinated by if he
can lift something as large and heavy as
the mud horn he can throw small things
around but they'd have to be
line-of-sight and he was stuff to be
focusing so far every time we've seen
him use the Force it's only been to save
the Mandalorians life when he thought
that he was in danger or to save his own
life when he thought that he was in
mortal peril like he understood innately
what was happening here when the droid
was raising the gun even if he didn't
necessarily understand how the gun works
as far as we know we've never seen him
used the Force to purposefully mess with
someone or in a non life-threatening
situation outside of his passive
abilities to sense what's going on
around him even though baby Yoda can't
speak right now at least we don't think
the
he can speak one of the cooler passive
ability is that baby Yoda has just
innately through the force even without
even thinking about it is the ability to
sense what's going on in the
Mandalorians head he can sense his
emotions he can't read his mind but he
can definitely sense how he feels that's
how he can tell the mandalorian is
afraid for his life and thinks he's
going to die like in this moment here
with the Mudd horn or something really
bad is about to happen around them so
early finale theory just beyond seeing
baby Yoda use more force abilities the
Mandalorian will probably take his
helmet off but just for baby Yoda and
because he still needs a signet his
signet will become the mark of the kid
like a marking of his tiny little three
fingered hand and he'll wear that as a
badge of honor fully accepting the kid
as part of his new family I've seen a
lot of questions asking how old baby
Yoda would have to be before he could
actually really start trained to become
a Jedi in a formal way
normal younglings would be between the
ages of 8 and 11 before they'd start
trained to become Jedi so if you tried
to scale 900 years down to a normal
human lifespan that would mean baby Yoda
would be around 80 before he started his
formal training he's about 50 when this
series begins in the rise of Skywalker
is about 25 to 28 years after what's
happening on this series right now so
reasonably it would be right after the
events of rise of Skywalker the baby
Yoda would actually be able to start
training to become a real Jedi I don't
consider it a spoiler to say that Jon
Favreau has already said that the kid
shows up during season two they've been
filming season two episodes for a while
now and everybody freaked out when they
dropped the kid during episode 6 like is
he going to be okay as for the whole
cloning subplot that they haven't
addressed since episode 3 that's still a
really big deal if they haven't talked
about in a couple episodes maybe they're
just able to slow the cloning plot down
so that is a couple of years off but
obviously there's not a ton of clones
running around during the present day of
the new trilogy so I think eventually
it's implied that they are successful in
defeating this big cloning plot they'll
probably get a little bit of help from
dr. Pershing who's still alive as the
end of episode 3 and shown that he cares
very much about the welfare of baby Yoda
they kind of started to set him up for a
similar arc as the Mandalorian he is
this member of the Imperial forces left
in the galaxy he's wearing their uniform
normally that would imply that he's a
bad person but he's already shown
through his actions that he doesn't
share their values and seems like he
doesn't
want anybody to get hurt the same way
the Mandalorian tried to stop Matt
Lanter former Anakin Skywalker from the
Clone Wars from getting killed by these
other bounty hunters please don't hurt
it's just a what did you do it I
protected if it wasn't for me he would
already be dead please so hopefully
he'll come back in the finale and they
can pay that off by having him help the
Mandalorian and the kids somehow
hopefully that explains what baby Oda is
capable of right now he's powerful but
there's a limit to that so they can give
you some realistic expectations for what
they can do with him in the finale but
what's gonna happen this week big
reminder is that Mandalorian Episode
seven is gonna be on Wednesday we get a
couple days early because rise of
Skywalker is coming out next weekend my
video for that will post on Wednesday
but I'm also supposed to see rise of
Skywalker early next week and I believe
I'm allowed to post my non-spoilery
review early Wednesday morning so that's
probably when that's gonna happen don't
worry I won't post any spoilers episode
9 videos until we get to the weekend and
people have a chance to actually see the
movie if there's any big Mandalorian or
Star Wars videos that you want me to do
just let me know in the comments
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
episode 6 video and click here for my
other video explaining why the Empire
wants baby Yoda so badly thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]